julia de funès philosophe auteur du
développement un personnel le succès
d'une imposture aux édition de
l'observatoire 2019 bonsoir louis de
funès merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france 55 jours de confinement
vous la philosophe que retenez-vous de
cette période que ce soit en termes
positifs ou négatifs
il y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire
puisqu'il a touché tous les pans de
l'existence mais simplement on est passé
là on est vraiment à la journée au jour
j on est passé d'une hégémonie de la
santé du sanitaire ou là on a vu que la
santé s'apparente à une morale puisque
les gestes barrière de vienne à des
comportements sociaux la santé devenue
de la politique
l'épidémie était considérée comme une
guerre bref la santé était omniprésente
dans notre société et comment des nos
actions et là on est passé on passe
aujourd'hui du côté de la surveillance
et plus seulement le sanitaire mais
c'est le contrôle et la surveillance qui
prennent le pas et je pense que c'est
leur le moment d'une vigilance accrue
puisque très vite on peut confondre la
protection et la domination et la
permission et la liberté mais la
permission c'est pas la liberté donc il
faut être très vigilant me semble-t-il
aujourd'hui sur ce conte sur le fait que
la liberté n'est pas une saveur mais un
droit quand vous dites domination ça
veut dire quoi vous faites partie de ces
gens qui pensent on a entendu quelques
invités avant voilà ce pain qu'il y
avait très peu de liberté que l'état
avait développé une forme
d'autoritarisme parce que vous partagez
cette analyse
c'est le message non je suis pas du tout
conspirationnistes et malveillantes en
dix ans le gouvernement ait l'intention
malveillante je me permets pas de juger
mais simplement quand on écoutait le
discours de déconfinement dévore
philippe on se rendait compte que le
contrôle était omniprésent et le
paradoxe où la magie du en même temps
c'est qu'il disait on va vous faire
confiance on va faire confiance aux
citoyens et en même temps on va
contrôler mais la confiance est de
contrôler ça va pas du tout ensemble
quand on fait confiance on lâche prise
s'il vous fait confiance je regarde pas
ce que vous faites un moment je le fais
un saut dans l'inconnu je parie sur vous
je crois en vous cedetim au logis même
du mot confiance considéré avec foi et
quand on contrôle d'un regard donc les
il ya des phases de contrôle nécessaires
il ya des phases de confiance mais les
deux domaines
concomitante c'est impossible donc là on
a très bien vu qu'on rentrait dans une
phase de contrôle et de surveillance
et quand les veaux le vocabulaire
employé était très parlants et peut-être
un peu anxiogène quand on parle de
brigade
quand on parle de mise en quarantaine on
a l'impression que le malade devient
quasiment un délinquant c'est cette
petite dérive là je dis pas qu'elle
existait encore une fois je n'accuse pas
le gouvernement mais qui me semble être
devoir être mise en alerte après c'est
justement 55 jours de confinement pensez
vous qu'il soit venu le temps peut-être
justement de plus de confiance et d'un
peu moins de contrôler les français
peuvent être des citoyens tout
simplement responsables de leur propre
destin en étant évidemment à vos rides
averti des conséquences
je ne sais pas si les les citoyens vont
être suffisamment responsable moi même
je sais pas comment je vais me comporter
parfois j'ai peut-être à être tenté
d'aller dans un magasin sans masque est
pas respectée forcément la halle
consignes donc je pense simplement que
le la vigilance et de se dire est ce
qu'on est vraiment on doit être à mon
sens dans une phase de contrôle
mais à ce moment là ne parlons pas de
confiance et quand on parle vraiment de
confiance alors à ce moment-là on lâche
prise
on responsabilise on responsabilise les
citoyens mais parler des deux en même
temps c'est ça qui me semble assez
hypocrite en tout cas d'un vocabulaire
d'aujourd'hui alors emmanuel macron lui
même parlé de se réinventer sachons nous
réinventer moi le premier pour vous pour
la philosophe est ce qu'il y aura un
avant et un après où finalement la vie
d'avant va va revenir comme avant
justement on aura vite tout oublié
je ne sais pas je pense que le temps
n'est pas aux prédictions hasardeuse en
tout cas c'est pas dans ce cadre là que
je me situe mais simplement à une
exigence que doublé de lucidité il ya
des choses qui ont déjà changé si je
prendrai des travail par exemple il
s'est généralisé de façon massive alors
qu'il y avait encore des entreprises
réfractaires au télétravail du avant le
confinement et cette rupture ce moment
difficile et malheureux a eu le bienfait
de généraliser cette pratique tant qu'il
ya des choses très concrètes qui se met
en place qui changent exemple
télétravail après ce sur quoi on peut
travailler c'est sur les représentations
qu'on a sur vous parlez de la
reconnaissance justement avant il
suffisait pas d'applaudir les soignants
du haut de son balcon avec un verre de
rosé et un ukulélé dans la main pour
juger que c'est suffisant bien sûr
qu'ils auraient un travail
c'est un impératif c'est un acte de
volonté c'est pas de l'espérance est ce
que finalement
on va le reconnaître il faut le vouloir
et il va falloir distinguer avoir le
courage de distinguer les métiers utiles
et nécessaires utiles et non nécessaire
et non utiles et non nécessaires et
adaptées à adapter évidemment une
politique fiscale et de rémunération
adapté
donc ça je pense que c'est pas
simplement de la prédiction du hasard
est ce que ça va venir à ce que ce
serait une fatalité
ça doit être un optimisme de volonté
justement vous parlez de ses
applaudissements
tous les soirs à 20h vous comprenez que
certains soignants ne les ai pas
forcément apprécié oui moi j'ai vu un
article est beau j'ai reçu beaucoup de
témoignages de médecins qui était
quelque chose de gênant de vente eux
parce que c'est on comprend très bien la
sympathie de ce geste encore une fois
mais néanmoins il apparaît on se dit
quand on applaudit on se dit on est
quand même quelqu'un vient et c'est
l'fun conscience ce narcissisme de
drapés dans de la bienfaisance et un peu
de gêne en sachant que les soignants
étaient dans la rue il ya quelques mois
donc je pense que la sympathie du geste
ne doivent pas anéantir les efforts que
suppose une véritable reconnaissance
mais c'est très difficile dans nos prix
d'admettre la reconnaissance parce que
la reconnaissance est une distinction et
vous savez on a un vieil héritage
aristocratique on a peur de distinguer
de reconnaître de valoriser certaines
professions plus que d'autres mais c'est
une des dérives démocratiques qui est
lié à l'égalisation à
l'indifférenciation qu'on voit partout
fleurir dans notre pays mais
l'indifférenciation mène à
l'indifférence et du coup là le manque
de reconnaissance n'est pas un oubli ou
une méchanceté mais c'est une dérive
démocratique grave si on n'a pas le cran
de nommer et de valoriser à leur juste
valeur les métiers les plus essentiels
et les faits les plus utiles à la nation
une question peut-être plus personnelle
pour terminer les films de votre aïeul
un louis de funès ont apporté beaucoup
de réconfort aux français pendant cette
période de confinement le service public
les à passer allègrement mais pas comme
d'ailleurs sur plusieurs chaînes
ça vous a touchée de voir à quel point
ça faisait du bien finalement de revoir
tous ces fils de louis de funès
bien sûr ça a touché toute ma famille
mes parents mes frères
absolument tout le monde on était pas on
n'était pas averti non plus qui aurait 7
faire voir là mais je crois que au delà
du talent et du génie de son jeu parce
qu'il ya d'autres acteurs qui sont
géniaux et qui ne paraissent pas aussi
souvent je crois qu'il a réussi sans le
vouloir mais le fait d'être un
intercesseur entre soi et soi même quand
on vous revoit un film on se retrouve
soi même le regardant avec ses parents
et ses grands parents c'est pour ça
qu'on se sent si bien peut-être que
c'est un refuge affectif de regarder ses
films là et c'est ce qui explique en
partie aussi la pérennité de ces de ses
films effectivement certainement mercier
je lis à des feux des steelers a enfin
un moteur du développement
un personnel entre parenthèses à succès
d'une imposture merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur écran